[Music]
all right
picture this you're shroud and you load
into an apex legend server you make it
to the final three and you are cruising
to an easy dub
but then out of nowhere this happens
oh well hot dab okay
your first reaction would have to be
that this kid's a cheater
right he's got 12 frags oh he's cheating
unless he's just really good wait is he
insane
but as shroud quickly learned the
tempest he found himself in
was all too real
i'm the best player
[Applause]
get out of my lobby on that day
shroud stepped into the cross harris of
monsoon an up-and-coming apex legends
player
these days the 21 year old is one of the
biggest names in apex
but to get there he didn't just have to
battle his way through online arenas and
aim trainers
he had to fight homelessness throughout
all the homelessness the one thing
that i did keep was my computer
competing in overwatch realm real
so many different games trying to make
anything work from working in a kitchen
for 60 hours a week to setting up his pc
in a
taco bell monsoon did whatever it took
to be a pro gamer
and since then he's taken competitive
apex by storm
and gentrifying he's the last remaining
player in complexity they have it within
their grasp
they push in it's gonna be the moment
for them
complexity get the story they so
desperately wanted
all right folks before we get into
monsoon's incredible story i want to
make sure that you are all sub to the
channel so please
hit the sub button hit that notification
bell and help us get to 2 million subs
alright back to monsoon now before he
was complexity's star apex fragger
monsoon and his family had a lot of
financial difficulties when he was
growing up
he spent most of his childhood sleeping
in cars tents and hotel rooms and he was
homeless as a teenager
i grew up in the bay area of california
during my prime years of high school and
middle school
and spent on and off about two years
homeless not only did monsoon's living
situation prevent him from finishing
high school but he and his wife had to
hop from
state to state just to make ends meet at
one point they were sleeping on a table
in a trailer that was home to five
people and three dogs
in fact the only way that monsoon was
able to stay afloat was his other
passion
cooking he grinded at a 60 hour a week
kitchen job that paid him 14 dollars an
hour
still monsoon's real goal was to become
a professional gamer
one more stop frozen friends he stopped
pushing stop brandon selfridge stop
friends
he tried everything from cs go to realm
royale and was determined to bring his
talents to some game's world stage
i'm not an engagement right now so i can
take that uh oh [ __ ]
but since he didn't have a stable place
to live monsoon had to set up his pc
anywhere he could taking any and every
opportunity to grind
he even played in a taco bell buying
baja blast every hour to stay on the
wi-fi while he was trying to qualify for
an overwatch team
a lot of times i've set up my pc in
friends houses or pc cafes or
hotels or anywhere that i really could
to kind of get on practice
but then at the start of 2019 a new
shooter emerged
apex legends this is my favorite part
exciting part hero shooter part battle
royale
apex was a dream come true for monsoon
within no time he was fragging out on
twitch determined to make himself one of
the game's first stars
eventually monsoon quit his restaurant
job to commit to apex full time
he moved to las vegas and cut his teeth
on weeklies for the better part of a
year before getting signed by flyquest
what's going on everybody flyquest
apex family my name is monsoon i'm one
of the three players for apex legends uh
flyquest's roster
and then in august 2019 playing a random
match under flyquest banner
monsoon hit the flick that would change
his life
after popping off on shroud in front of
the entire world
monsoon became an overnight sensation
yeah
that's the best player at apex legends
seven thousand viewers holy fudge
dude shroud thank you so much for
shouting out me sent by
i appreciate you so much homie in
addition to being
absolutely cracked monsoon was also
super charismatic and injected
tons of personality into his gameplay no
grave
can hold my body down
in the fall he flew to poland to compete
in the apex legends pre-season
invitational and then the reason why i
want to start with flyquest is because
monsoon has recently joined them
he was a substitute for tempo storm uh
way back at x games and he is one of the
most individually skilled players that
we have at this tournament especially
when it comes to sniping and
using the longbow etc or the craiber
look at flyquest now it's a one it's
right now mvp versus flyquest this is
not a match point game but one of these
teams will win
it's gonna be one knock here for mvp two
knocks yes indeed
mvp closes it out and we have more apex
legends still to come
tonight unfortunately flyquest hadn't
quite worked out their kinks
and despite making it to the
tournament's final day they finished in
a disappointing 17th place
it took us good seven games to get
rolling unfortunately that's not
anything that we enjoy doing and our
moral
morale was was pretty pretty low man
within three months of joining flyquest
monsoon was picked up by complexity
where he'd be able to practice at a
state-of-the-art training facility in
texas
signing to complexity is the best thing
that's ever happened in my life
this organization is the best org in the
entire world over the course of the next
year monsoon worked tirelessly to break
into the top tier of na apex
unfortunately complexity consistently
struggled to make it past
top four despite monsoon's incredible
individual achievements
and then through the barrel monsoon's
gonna connect for another one squad left
complexity is hunting
they smell blood they're gonna find it
and that's gonna be a victory coming
through
for complexity what a performance from
this squad
the situation only got worse as
complexity came out of the second summer
circuit in an unthinkable 12th place
something had to change
and complexity made a roster move trying
to turn things around
now shawnee's got to finish off this job
in a big massive shot make that two
and he's doing all of the work here for
complexity even though monsoon went down
the damage that he'd done
once again
let's take a look at what they see on
the board everybody collective side
complexity
breaking it out on top with 68 points
sadly come playoffs complexity's old
habits caught up with them
despite coming into the tournament as a
juggernaut they couldn't quite secure
that top spot
complexity the only one on the ground
currently in zone with tlg
able to find something complexity looks
like they're the ones going down it's
complexity down but clg is still alive
the shotgun battle is here it's two
[Music]
they are your champions of the americas
in
summer after finishing first second and
third in each of the respective autumn
circuits complexity went into the year's
final playoff spout as a bit of a
question mark
but when the chips were down and monsoon
had a chance to come up huge for his
team
he did the impossible complexity does
have the
player advantage here monsoon going in
trying to take down the last player
which is eures he actually does it
and gentrifying he's the last remaining
player in complexity they have it within
their grasp
they push in it's gonna be the moment
for them
complexity get the story they so
desperately wanted
since discovering apex back in 2019
monsoon has gone from a nomad to a
world-class competitor
he's beaten nearly insurmountable odds
to become not only one of his region's
finest fraggers but also
it's most inspiring he's run his race
achieved his dream and shown time and
time again that for a lot of people
esports isn't just entertainment it's a
way for literally anyone to pull
themselves up by their bootstraps
and turn their passion into success and
stability
because against every odd that's exactly
what monsoon did thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification
bell for unique bite size videos you
won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages